former UEFA president Michel Platini has
been detained in connection with an
investigation into the award of the 2022
soccer world cup to Qatar in 2010 now
Platini is being held for questioning by
French authorities at the
anti-corruption office outside Paris the
decision to award the tournament to
Qatar was highly controversial Latini
has originally said he was going to vote
for the US and then changed his mind
after a meeting with the leader of the
Gulf State for more on the story I'm
joined by Jonathan crane from DW sports
desk welcome Jonathan first of all how
significant is this development well
this is a very major develop they're
very significant developments I think in
a story that's never really gone away
because ever since Qatar was awarded the
2022 World Cup back in 2010 there's been
this shadow of alleged corruption
hanging over it
Michel Platini was one of the people as
we said who voted for Qatar sitting on
FIFA's like his Executive Committee at
the time
Platini is a legend of French football
he was the way for president the head of
European football's governing body back
then so he had a vote he was even ticked
actually to replace then FIFA president
Sepp Blatter before the PES downfall in
2015 so he really is a big fish a big
fish in tell us now about the
investigation what's going on well
beyond his detention we don't really
know too much at this stage as you said
he's been taken to this anti-corruption
office west of Paris that story first
reported by the French outlet media Park
has now been confirmed by French
judicial authorities but because it's an
ongoing ongoing investigation they
really can't say too much more at this
stage where were yet to hear from
platini's lawyer
Platini has consistently denied any
wrongdoing what we do know is the French
authorities have been investigating the
bidding process into the 2018 and 2022
World Cups looking at things like
corruption influence-peddling also
detained a Sophie Dion who was former
sports advisor to then French President
Nicolas Sarkozy
and his right-hand man for
right Herman Claude gale also been taken
in for questioning but as a witness and
I understand a Johnathan that the
investigators are particularly
interested in a meeting Michel Platini
had back in 2010 what happened well
there's always been a lot of intrigue
over platini's choice to vote for Qatar
back in 2010 the meeting as you
mentioned was held in secret in Paris
just before that vote it was hosted by
then President Nicolas Sarkozy Platini
was present
so was the then Crown Prince of Qatar
who's now the Emir now basically Platini
had promised Sepp Blatter according to
Sepp Blatter that he was going to vote
for the United States there was this
gentlemen's agreement Platini then
according to Blatter rode back on that
promise to vote for Qatar now he's
denied it was because Sarkozy told him
to specifically no Platini himself as
admitted he knew it was probably the
right thing that he should be doing but
Jonathan back in 2017 FIFA's own
investigation found no corruption in the
bidding process so what's changed yeah
this is the Garcia report finally
released in 2017 is that there was no
evidence of improper activity by the bid
team and though it did also say didn't
quite meet the standards required but
alongside this FIFA investigation we've
also had other judicial investigations
the French one there's a Swiss one we
know the FBI in the United States is
also looking into FIFA because the
decision to award Qatar this tournament
has always raised eyebrows temperatures
in the summer reach 50 degrees hardly
ideal for playing football and though
the tournament has now been pushed to
the winter I think the questions about
Qatar have never gone away and this is
the latest development in this long
story and we'd have to see where this
investigation goes Jonathan crane from
DW sports says thank you very much